An opportunity to be you or someone you know vegetarians - has made us think of making an intellectual experience.
What would happen if everyone in the world became vegetarians?
What impact will this have on our lives and the planet?
Before we begin, we fully declare: None of the vegetarian AsapSCIENCE
The global rate of vegetarians is slim, ranging from 4-5% in the US and Canada
And just over 30% in India. As a result, there are about 20 billion chickens, 1.5 billion cows and over one billion sheep
And about one billion pigs in the world.
Without humans eating meat to form a market, whole herds of domestic animals
It will disappear
This Massiverg large tracts of land. About 33 million square kilometers
Of the land used for grazing - an area the size of the continent of Africa.
This does not even include agricultural land designated for animal feed crops.
Some of them will be used to increase vegetable crops, but most of the land is currently used as pasture
Are actually drier than grow crops. Without the addition of humans to industrial fertilizers, these lands
May become a deserts, but if managed properly, agricultural land may revert to its natural state of
Pastures and forests, which will help to overcome global climate change
In the end, remove the trees consumed for carbon dioxide from the atmosphere for planting
Was the main cause of high levels of carbon dioxide in the world.
Cows and other herbivores also affect the climate by producing amounts of methane,
Which has a 25 times greater capacity than carbon dioxide to heat the planet. In addition to loss
Forests and other impacts, livestock production accounts for 15% of emissions
Global warming, more than the combined aircraft, trains and cars of the world combined.
In fact, many scientists believe that reducing meat consumption may be one of the best strategies
Effective management of climate change.
The plant diet will also reduce water consumption by about 70% of the world's drinking water
Consumed in agriculture. It takes 15,000 liters of water to produce a kilogram of beef
6000 liters of pork, and 4000 liters of chicken meat compared this to 1600 liters of grain crops
900 liters for fruits and 600 liters for garden vegetables. Patakid, a kilogram of meat is rich
With lots of calories to meet the weight of the fruit, but even if compared to the proportion of water
For calorie calories from available food energy, beef is still 5 times thick with water
More fruits, 7 times thicker vegetables and 20 times thicker grains
If there are any defects in the plant diet? Well we will leave without a cheap source
For many animal products such as animal skins or grease
Which are used in the manufacture of cosmetics, candles and detergents. While the plant alternatives
Exist, but their production has to be increased, which means more land to be used for crop production
And change them from their nature.
The more complex truth is that raising and caring for animals is a full-time job
To more than a billion people - mostly small farmers in developing countries
Some may move to produce milk, eggs or even vegetable crops
But many of them will face a life-changing life
Of course, any attempt to increase vegetarian thought will be more gradual than a categorical shift.
Surprisingly, trends actually go in the opposite direction
In places like India and China, people have become richer than before, and as a result, they are consuming more meat
Eliminating the declines in other countries
So, we tried to become vegetarians for 21 consecutive days as a kind of experiment
In our class AsapTHOUGHT. Watch the section if you want to see how it went, and teach us
Of experience and how we felt about it.
And subscribe to more scientific sections weekly!